deep in the jungle there's a fungus that
infects creatures and turns them into
zombies this deadly fungus known as
cordyceps has the ability to take out
entire species what if this fungus
infected you by touching your skin or
just breathing it in could the cordyceps
fungus turn you into a zombie what would
it do to your body and how likely is it
that this will happen to you this is
what if and here's what would happen if
you were infected by the cordyceps
fungus the cordyceps fungus works when
its spores land on an insect body and
take leak in its muscles the spores then
control the insect making it move to a
location that's perfect for the fungi to
reproduce the fungus forces the insect
to chomp down on a leaf and it will then
stay there until it dies the parasite
will feed off the creature and grow for
weeks so it can release more spores and
infect more insects now how would this
work if it happened to you
if this fungal parasite could jump from
insects to humans it would most likely
be an airborne infection places like
cities public transportation and tunnels
would all be danger zones where you
could potentially catch the cordyceps
fungus it's likely that the fungus would
attack your body as any other parasite
might when you first become infected
you'll begin to feel some symptoms
you've probably felt before a fever
abdominal pain weakness and vomiting are
all possible consequences you might also
notice yourself getting depressed as the
cordyceps could affect your dopamine
levels some of these effects might be
familiar but what isn't is how the
fungus would spread through your body as
time goes on the fungus would start to
take over your nervous system since
you're a lot bigger than something like
an insect it would take months for the
cordyceps to take full control of you as
this is happening
the fungus would grow throughout your
arms and legs
when it spreads far enough in your body
it can gain control over you you could
do your best to fight it off but once
it's inside of you there's really
nothing you can do your brain would
still be running but you wouldn't have
control over what you do with it after
all the cordyceps primary purpose is to
spread as much as it can and to do that
it would trap you inside an enclosed
area so it could grow and spread through
your body even further after a couple of
weeks you would die in that spot and now
that you're dead the cordyceps fungus
can continue to spread turning you into
what's known as a fruiting body
this is when spores and fungi would
start to come out of you they come out
from everywhere that doesn't have any
hard bone blocking its way and now that
this has happened the fungus and spores
can spread even further infecting more
and more people luckily we don't need to
worry about this sort of thing happening
to us cordyceps can't infect humans as
our bodies are better than insects at
attacking pathogens so you can rest easy
knowing you will turn into a zombie from
these things but what if instead of you
turning into one there was a full-on
zombie apocalypse crumb we'll leave that
story for another what-if
[Music]